Okay, so more SQL.
Let's start with the basic statement we've been using so far--
Select * From Links.
Let's add a Where clause where votes are > 10.
That gives us only the links that have a few votes.
And let's add a new type of clause.
This is the Order By clause,
and this says to sort the results.
I've got Select * From Links--we're familiar with that--
where Votes is > 10--and we're familiar with that.
Additionally, all of those rows that you're returning to us,
order them by the number of votes.
And by default, the votes are in ascending order,
but if you can't remember that,
it's perfectly fine to specify.
You can say ASC for ascending
or DESC for descending.
I usually specify because I can never remember which is default.
Pretty simple statement.
One other thing to note is that the Where clause is not required.
It's never required.
So I could change this to look like this.
Just Select * From Links, Order by Votes Descending.
That would give me all of the links sorted descending by votes
with no constraints whatsoever.
Okay, here's a quiz.
We're in the same file, and we're still manipulating our query function.
And what I'd like you to do this time is make the function query,
return the IDs of the links that were submitted by user 62443,
and sort them by submission time ascending.
And remember that a submission time
is the column called Submitted_Time.
Okay, good luck.